Welcome, curious minds, to
another deep dive.
Today, we're plunging head first
into a topic that sparks just
incredibly strong feelings and
endless debate.
Yet it's often surprisingly
misunderstood the true nature of
a police officer.
You know, there's this prevalent
modern sentiment, a kind of
hopeful wish, really, that law
enforcement could be, well, a
lot of things.
We often hear the desire for
them to be multifaceted
community figures, almost like
therapists or, you know, social
workers capable of softening the
world's edges when chaos
inevitably erupts.
And that's precisely our
mission.
With this deep dive, we're going
to try and strip away those
romanticizations, those well
meaning but ultimately
uncomfortable emissions to truly
understand what a law
enforcement officer and Elio
fundamentally is, and perhaps
more importantly, what they
fundamentally are not.
And we're basing this directly
on the rich source material
we've gathered.
We'll offer a well a clear eyed
reminder of their core role,
weaving in historical context
some surprising data and some
compelling analogies to
illuminate this complex reality.
This isn't about taking aside,
not at all.
It's about providing you with a
nuanced, practical understanding
of a role that impacts all of
us, so you can be truly well
informed in your own thinking.
Prepare to have some assumptions
challenged and hopefully gain a
much clearer perspective.
OK, let's unpack this then.
When we talk about policing
today, there's this pervasive,
almost gentle wish floating
around, especially visible and,
you know, public discourse.
It's the idea that officers
should embody this incredible
blend, part community therapist,
part moral guide, part social
worker.
The vision is that they'll be
there to soften the harshness of
the world, to bring a calming,
almost therapeutic presence when
life gets chaotic, handling
complex social issues with
compassion and, you know, de
escalation alone.
It's a very appealing image,
isn't it?
This idea of a police officer as
a universal problem solver, a
kind of civic Saint Bernard,
ready to offer aid and comfort.
It absolutely is, and it's a
vision that's circulating with
incredible velocity, almost like
gospel in certain circles.
There's a strong push, for
instance, to suggest that before
you even think about dialing
911, before you summon that
uniform presence of the state,
you should pause.
You should wave very carefully
whether police involvement might
actually make the situation
worse, whether it might escalate
something that could otherwise
be resolved with a softer touch.
We've all probably encountered
some version of this, perhaps
packaged neatly in those
shareable social media carousels
or earnest public service
announcements advising.
Always ask the victim whether
they feel safe involving the
police.
Remember, to some, 911 might be
violence.
Wow.
That's a powerful statement. 911
might be violence.
It's really designed to make you
stop and think, truly consider
the potential ramifications of a
call for help, isn't it?
It truly is.
And look, to be fair, there's an
undeniable kernel of wisdom in
that caution.
A vital historical truth
embedded within it.
If we look at the historical
record, it is undeniably crowded
with moments where the badge,
despite its stated purpose of
protecting and serving, did far
more harm than could.
Think of the era of Jim Crow
policing, the enforcement of
discriminatory laws, or even
more recently documented
instances of excessive force and
racial profiling.
There are countless historical
instances where figures sworn to
protect ended up failing
spectacularly, even becoming
agents of harm themselves.
Acknowledging that uncomfortable
historical reality is crucial
for any honest discussion about
law enforcement.
What often gets lost in these
well meaning refrains, what is
almost always omitted, is a
clear, unvarnished understanding
of what a police officer
actually is, and, crucially,
what they are not.
That's the critical omission
that leads to so much confusion
and, frankly, public
disappointment.
Exactly.
And Speaking of romanticized
images, let's talk about the old
beat cop.
You know, that classic, almost
nostalgic image of the local
Bobby, The friendly officer
walking a specific patrol area,
often stereotyped as Irish and
old movies, perhaps tipping his
hat, breaking up a minor scuffle
between kids with a fatherly
word, watching over his specific
patch like some kind of kind
umple, an omnipresent,
benevolent guardian.
It's a comforting picture, isn't
it?
A figure of approachable,
fatherly authority who knows
everyone's name, all the
neighborhood secrets.
It's a comforting picture, yes,
and very, very romanticized, but
it's absolutely essential to
debunk that myth for clarity.
Even that seemingly benign
figure, the Bobby, was never the
neighborhood's roving social
worker.
He wasn't equipped or trained to
be.
His primary role from the very
beginning into the very end of
his shift was fundamentally that
of a boundary marker.
A boundary marker?
Yeah, he was a walking, visible
reminder that chaos would simply
not be allowed to flourish
unchecked in his territory, in
his specific designated area of
patrol.
His physical presence, the
uniform, the badge, these were a
constant, tangible deterrent.
His job was to make it known
that there were rules, a civic
code, and that these rules would
be enforced.
He was a symbol of order, a line
drawn in the sand, not a
dispenser of therapy or a
mediator of deeply personal
family disputes.
He was there to say essentially
this far and no further.
So not a confessor, not a
mediator, just a line in the
sand, a visible demarcation of
what's acceptable and what's
not.
And that brings us directly to
the classic motto we see
emblazoned on police cruisers
and badges everywhere.
Protect and serve.
That.
It sounds so straightforward, so
noble, so all-encompassing.
But how often do we actually
stop to consider what that truly
means in the context of what
we've just discussed about
boundaries and order?
That's a key point, and it's
where a significant public
misinterpretation often arises.
The phrase protect and serve is
widely misunderstood, or at
least interpreted to a very
soft, individualized lens.
It most emphatically does not
mean protect the 1 causing havoc
at the expense of everyone else.
Right.
That's a common assumption
though.
It is, but it's a dangerous
misinterpretation, as if the
police are there to ensure
everyone, even the lawbreaker,
feels safe and unthreatened in
their actions, or to make sure
no one's feelings are hurt
during an arrest.
No, what it means, unequivocally
is to protect the quiet,
unremarkable majority.
Think about it, when a
neighborhood is plagued by
repeat car break insurance, or a
corner shop owner is repeatedly
targeted by shoplifters, or a
family is subjected to a
continuous noise nuisance from a
defiant neighbor, The police
aren't there to mediate the
needs or expressions of the
person breaking the law.
They're there to enforce the
boundary for the people who just
want to live their lives without
fear, without their property
being violated, without their
peace being constantly
disrupted.
It's about enabling a stable,
peaceful environment for the
many, even if that means
confronting the disruptive,
often forceful actions of the
few.
It's about upholding the social
contract, not negotiating
individual desires.
That certainly shifts the
perspective, moving away from
individual comfort to societal
stability as the primary goal,
and that takes us directly into
the fundamental identity of
these officers.
Every working police officer you
encounter, they use a specific
shorthand to describe
themselves.
Leo, law enforcement officer.
It's concise and it's very
telling, isn't it?
It is indeed telling the Leo.
It encapsulates the very essence
of their role.
And what's crucial here is what
that shorthand isn't.
It isn't law negotiation
officer.
It's not neighborhood mediation
officer, and it is absolutely,
unequivocally not community
therapist.
The profession itself, through
this very designation, clarifies
its reality.
L ES are trained at their core
to enforce the code that the
broader society has written.
Now, that code, the law, is
undeniably imperfect.
It's always evolving, and
sometimes, yes, it can be clumsy
or blunt in its application.
But it is a code nonetheless, A
fundamental framework for how we
are meant to coexist within a
civil society.
They're not there to customize
that law for every household,
private folklore, or every
streets informal treaty about
how things should be.
They are certainly not sent to
arbitrate competing folkways or
personal grievances when those
clash violently and threaten
public order.
Their core function, when all
else fails, when dialogue breaks
down, when compliance is
refused, is clear.
They are there to draw a line,
and they are there to hold it.
That's what law enforcement
truly means.
It's about ensuring that the
agreed upon rules of society are
not simply suggestions, but
enforceable boundaries.
To draw a line and hold it,
that's a powerful image and a
stark contrasts.
Some of the softer, more
empathetic roles, we sometimes
wish they embodied.
So if we're trying to truly
understand their role, this
fundamental function of
deterrence and maintaining
boundaries, what's good metaphor
for this line drawing and
holding function, this
fundamental, often latent force?
The source material offers a
pretty vivid one the guard dog
metaphor.
It's perhaps the most insightful
metaphor for truly grasping the
police role, because it captures
the essence of deterrence
without constant action.
And to illustrate it, the source
uses what it calls the parable
of the trade in Glock.
Imagine for a moment handling a
police trade in pistol, say a
Glock 17 or 19.
When you inspect it, you
immediately notice the striking
physical paradox.
The external parts, the slide,
the frame, the grip are often
heavily chewed up.
You see clear marks from years
of holster wear, the constant
friction of being drawn,
reholstered, carried every
single day.
It's a visible testament to
constant readiness, a weapon
always on the hip, always ready
for immediate deployment.
But then you dissemble it and
you look inside the internal
mechanism.
It's often near pristine.
It's fired few around, sometimes
significantly fewer than a
civilian might put through a
similar gun in a single year at
a shooting range.
That's fascinating.
So the outside tells a story of
constant, relentless readiness,
a tool always present, always on
standby, while the inside
suggests the weapon itself is
rarely actually used in its
ultimate capacity.
What does that paradox reveal
about the officers daily
reality?
Precisely this physical paradox,
this stark contrast between
external wear and internal
pristine condition, is the daily
posture of the guard dog.
The teeth, metaphorically
speaking, remains she'sed.
They aren't constantly biting or
attacking.
They are not deployed in every
interaction.
But the very existence of those
teeth, the knowledge that they
are there and can be deployed if
necessary, that deters far more
chaos and violence than they
ever actually need to inflict.
It's a latent possibility of
force that maintains order, not
its constant application.
It's the silent threat that
keeps the peace.
Now here's where the irony, and
indeed the tragedy comes in.
The same tool that Glock and
underfunded departments with
insufficient training budgets
and often under arrested
officers often turns on its own
handler.
We're talking about accidental
self-inflicted gunshot wounds,
not from a shootout, but from
this handling, from insufficient
practice, from fatigue.
These surprisingly happen
frequently enough in big cities
like DC that they've earned A
grim nickname.
Getting bit.
It's gallows humor among Cox, a
dark joke shared in the locker
room to cope with the reality of
an avoidable, often embarrassing
injury.
Getting bit?
Wow, that's quite a vivid and
uncomfortable phrase.
What does that tell us about the
broader reality of policing
beyond just a specific incident?
How does a specific tragic
accidental discharge point to a
systemic issue of inadequate
preparation versus just an
individual flaw?
It speaks to a significant gap,
a chasm really, between the myth
of elite precision, the popular,
often unrealistic idea that
officers are always perfectly
trained, perfectly controlled,
almost superhuman in their
mastery of their tools, and the
stark truth of an ordinary civil
servant.
These are real people doing an
extraordinarily demanding job
under immense pressure, but
often with all too ordinary and
sometimes inadequate preparation
and resources.
The getting bit phenomena
highlights that the tools of
deterrence require constant,
rigorous and expensive training.
Without that consistent
investment, without the hours on
the range, the repetition, the
scenario based drills that build
muscle memory under stress, even
the tools meant to protect can
become a liability.
The guard dog needs to be not
just present, but incredibly
well trained to ensure it only
barks and bites when absolutely
necessary and never turns on its
own handler through negligence
or poor preparation.
It exposes the difficult truth
that an officer is a human being
with human limitations, working
within a system that may not
always fully equip them for the
extraordinary demands placed
upon them.
That puts a very human face on
the tools of enforcement and on
the roll itself.
And it ties into another point.
We often discuss the desire for
police to be something more,
something idealized.
People project these incredible,
almost mythical roles onto them.
But an officer is not a paladin,
nor are they a priest.
That's the source of so much
public confusion and subsequent
disappointment.
People want the police to be
something they've never been,
and frankly, we're never
designed or trained to be.
They want a paladin that
incorruptible stainless night,
always on call, always morally
pure, dispensing mercy, grace,
and rough wisdom all at once.
They want a figure who can
understand every nuance of a
situation, make a morally
perfect judgement, and resolve
conflict with a word.
But a police officer is not your
moral champion, nor are they a
figure of spiritual guidance.
They're not your pastor.
They're to offer spiritual
guidance or absolve sins or to
provide deep counseling on
personal struggles.
They're certainly not your local
mediator whose job is to bend
the law to accommodate each
household's unique tragic back
story or individual
circumstances saying, oh, I
understand why you broke the
law.
You had a rough childhood.
That simply isn't their
function.
So they aren't there to
contextualize the law based on
individual circumstances or
personal tragedies.
Their primary role isn't about
discerning the deep why of
someone's actions in the moment
of enforcement.
Not in that sense, no.
They are at their core and arm
of the state, and as an arm of
the state, they are fallible.
They're human, and the tools
they wield can be blunt.
They are trained to weigh risk
quickly and to do what the law
demands when negotiation fails,
when voluntary compliance isn't
achieved, or when an immediate
threat requires intervention.
Their purpose is enforcement,
not empathetic arbitration of
personal lows.
That's a crucial distinction.
Furthermore, for many officers,
this isn't a sacred calling, not
in the same way a soldier might
feel bound by an almost
transcendent oath for a
significant number.
This is a pension government
job.
They work for 20 years if
they're lucky, sometimes more,
and then they retire.
It's not a holy calling, nor is
a patriotic in the transcendent
spiritual sense some might
imagine when they think of
uniformed service.
It is work often performed under
immense pressure, with the ever
present latent possibility that
any mundane encounter, a routine
traffic stop, a noise complaint,
might instantly erupt into a
moment that will define, if not
tragically end a life.
It's a job with unique and
profound pressures, but it is,
at its heart, still a job with
benefits, a paycheck and a
career path.
That puts a very practical spin
on it, moving away from any sort
of spiritual or heroic
idealization.
It grounds the discussion in a
very tangible reality.
And interestingly, the source
material suggests even popular
culture, something as ubiquitous
as Spider Man, understands this
Simpler, more brutal, brutal
honesty about immediate
intervention and honesty that
our polite discourse often
conveniently forgets or actively
tries to suppress.
It's absolutely true, and it's a
telling cultural touchstone.
Think about it.
When Spider Man swings across
the street and webs up a mugger
who's threatening someone with a
knife, what does he do?
He certainly doesn't pause to
ask whether the young man
brandishing the weapon had a
challenging upbringing or if his
father was absent, or if he's
suffering from systemic
inequities that led him to that
desperate act.
He doesn't sit him down on the
curb and initiate A therapeutic
dialogue about early childhood
stressors or the societal
factors contributing to his
criminal behavior.
No, definitely not.
No, what he does is immobilize
him quickly, efficiently,
decisively, without ceremony,
and then he leaves him there for
the police to deal with.
There's no public outcry from
the audience, no calls for
community accountability circles
or restorative justice
interventions for the person who
just tried to rob someone.
So the fictional hero doesn't
engage in social work or therapy
or deep analysis of root causes.
He applies immediate, decisive
force to stop the immediate
threat.
Exactly.
And the reason we don't protest,
the reason we nod along and
cheer for Spider Man in that
moment, is because there's this
deeply ingrained, unspoken
consensus within us that
sometimes force must meet force.
Sometimes the problem at hand,
the immediate threat to life or
property, is not one that can be
resolved by sympathy alone, or
by dialogue, or by understanding
the root causes of someone's
behavior in that immediate,
dangerous moment.
In those instances where an
immediate tangible threat
exists, the primary objective,
the most urgent need, is to stop
the harmful action, protect the
innocent and maintain the line
of basic public order.
Spider Man is a cultural
touchstone, reflects a very
primal understanding that for
certain acts of violence or
aggression, immediate, decisive
intervention, even forceful
intervention, is required.
The deeper societal problems,
the root causes, the therapeutic
interventions, these are for
others to address after the
immediate threat is contained in
the line is held.
It highlights the crucial
distinction between stopping an
immediate threat and addressing
complex social issues, a
distinction that frequently gets
blurred, sometimes dangerously
so, in the broader public
conversation around policing.
It's a stark reminder, isn't it,
that some problems simply can't
be talked away in the moment
they're unfolding.
That sometimes immediate action,
even force, is the only option.
And understanding that primal
need for intervention is
critical when we look at how
this role, this core identity of
the law enforcement officer, has
actually evolved over time.
Because the guard dog of today
is a product of a century of
shifting societal needs,
technological advancements, and
often public reaction to crisis.
So let's dive into a century of
policing, how officers are
trained, the data that often
gets overlooked, and the
inherent dilemmas they face.
What did police training look
like back in, say, the 1930s and
50s?
Well, back then the picture was
vastly different from today.
Almost unrecognizable, really.
Local patrolmen essentially
learned on the job mostly by
doing, by observing senior
officers, and by navigating
their beat.
Many city police departments at
the time operated heavily on
political patronage systems,
meaning the local war boss or
precinct captain often decided
who got the job, not necessarily
based on meritocratic
qualifications or extensive
training.
It was often about who you knew
or who you were connected to.
Right connections over
qualifications.
Exactly.
Formal police academies were
rare or very rudimentary
firearms training incredibly
rare.
Many beat cops went their entire
careers without ever drawing a
gun in anger, let alone firing
it at another human being.
The iconic image of The Walking
beat cop, which we romanticize
today, emerge from these dense,
often immigrant neighborhoods.
They were indeed a visible line
of order, a physical presence, A
deterrent, but certainly not a
roving therapist.
Their job was primarily to keep
the peace, deal with immediate,
often petty disruptions like
breaking up bar brawls,
directing traffic or dragging
drunks to the drunk tank, not
mediating complex trauma or
providing social services.
It was very practical on the
ground.
Learn as you go approach heavily
influenced by local politics and
the specific needs of the
immediate community.
So very decentralized,
practical, almost reactive
approach, heavily influenced by
local politics.
Then we move into the tumultuous
1960s and 70s, an era marked by
profound social upheaval.
What fundamentally changed in
policing during that period?
What forced that change?
Oh, the civil rights unrest and
the widespread urban riots of
that era.
I think Watson 65 or the mass of
eruptions in Detroit and Newark
in 67 really forced big city
departments to modernize, and
often to do so rapidly and
sometimes brutally.
The traditional, relatively
unarmed beat cop model was seen
as completely insufficient to
handle large scale civil
disorder.
As a result, riot control and
officer survival training
suddenly took extreme
precedence.
Far more than any emphasis on
conflict mediation or community
relations.
A big shift in priority is huge
shift.
This is also the period when the
SWAT concept emerged.
The LAPD, for instance,
pioneered paramilitary units
after the Watts riots
specifically designed for high
risk situations, barricaded
suspects, large scale crowd
control.
Police academies became more
formalized during this period,
but their approach is still
varied wildly.
Some focused on public relations
and community outreach, others
almost purely on the application
of force and tactical maneuvers.
It was reactive modernization
driven by a perceived need for a
more militarized response to
widespread social upheaval and
rising crime rates.
And that paramilitary approach
seems to have truly taken hold
and expanded significantly in
the 1980s and 90s, especially
with the nationwide war on drugs
effort.
How did that specifically shape
police tactics and training?
Absolutely.
The war on drugs, a massive
federal initiative,
fundamentally brought policing
into a full paramilitary style,
pushing it far beyond just
specialized SWAT teams.
Departments across the country
acquired surplus military
equipment.
They adopted aggressive tactics
like battering Rams for forced
entry, flash bang grenades for
disorientation and widespread no
knock warrants, which allowed
officers to enter homes without
warning, often based just on
suspected drug activity.
Which sounds inherently risky.
Extremely risky.
And while firearms training did
improve for specialized tactical
teams, becoming more rigorous
and frequent, many patrol
officers still only fire their
weapons maybe once or twice a
year, just enough to meet
minimum qualification standards.
This era also saw the widespread
adoption of the broken windows
theory proposed by criminologist
James Q Wilson and George L
Kelling.
The core idea was that visible
signs of crime, broken windows,
graffiti, public drinking create
an environment that encourages
more serious crime.
So police were told to
aggressively chase every petty
infraction.
Public drinking, turnstile
jumping, panhandling, loitering.
The idea was stopping these
small things would prevent
bigger ones.
To restore order by cracking
down on minor stuff.
That was the theory to restore
order.
But in practice, especially when
applied broadly and without
nuance, this approach often
shattered Community Trust,
particularly in marginalized
communities.
It led to more arrests for minor
offenses and a widespread
feeling of over policing rather
than genuine community safety or
partnership.
It fundamentally shifted the
focus from broad peacekeeping to
aggressive enforcement of minor
infractions.
Then 911 hit in 2001.
That must have fundamentally
shifted things again in the
2000s and 20 tens, introducing a
completely new paradigm for
domestic policing.
It did, fundamentally redefining
everything from a federal
perspective.
The immediate aftermath of 9/11
saw the channeling of massive
federal grants through programs
like the Department of Homeland
Security.
These became available to local
police departments, leading to
the acquisition of armored
vehicles.
Advanced surveillance tech,
detection dogs, bomb squads,
even small town police forces
got this kind of equipment.
The focus shifted sharply to
counterterrorism and
preparedness for large scale
coordinated attacks.
And active shooter training.
Right.
Active shooter response training
ramped up dramatically.
It was completely revolutionized
after terrific events like
Columbine in 99 and Virginia
Tech in 2007.
Officers were now taught to
immediately engage a shooter
rather than waiting for SWAT.
That fundamentally changed how
patrol officers were taught to
respond to mass casualty events.
But simultaneously, during the
same period, a series of high
profile civilian shootings by
police, incidents like Ferguson,
the death of Tamir Rice,
Philando Castir ignited
widespread public outrage and
sparked demands for greater
transparency, leading to the
rapid adoption of body cameras,
a push for de escalation
training, and increased
accountability for police
actions.
So the era became characterized
by this fascinating, often
contradictory push and pull,
increased militarization on one
hand, and calls for significant
reform on the other.
And that tension seems to have
continued, maybe even
intensified, into the twenty 20s
and beyond, with concepts like
Defund the Police gaining real
prominence.
What's the current state of
police training and the overall
public conversation around it?
Yes, the Defund the Police and
Abolish the Police movements
became incredibly prominent,
gaining significant traction in
public discourse, particularly
after high profile incidents of
police misconduct.
Some cities responding to these
powerful calls did indeed slash
police budgets or reallocate
funds.
Others pivoted, experimenting
with alternative response teams
for certain types of calls, like
sending mental health crisis
workers instead of armed
officers to nonviolent mental
health emergencies.
However, a core, often
overlooked reality of police
training remains A striking
point of contention and concern.
The average US police Academy
training still ranges from only
about 600 to 900 hours
nationwide.
Only 600 to 900 hours.
Yeah, that's often significantly
less than the hours required for
a licensed Barber or a
cosmetologist or even an
electrician in many states,
which quite surprising, even
shocking when you consider the
life and death stakes of the
job.
The balance within that training
also remains remarkably
consistent.
It's still very heavy on
firearms proficiency, tactical
maneuvers, defensive tactics,
and legal code.
Well, de escalation techniques,
crisis intervention, and mental
health modules, though they
exist and are growing, still
constitute A relatively small
slice of the overall training
time.
It's a continuous, often
conflicting evolution driven by
reactive policy shifts in public
demand rather than a cohesive
long term vision.
That training hour comparison is
quite jarring.
It really highlights a
significant gap between public
expectation of a highly skilled,
multifaceted officer and the
practical preparation they often
receive.
Now let's get into some crucial
data points, the kind of BS
check that's often overlooked or
distorted in public discourse.
What objective numbers should we
really know about policing to
cut through the noise?
The data, when presented
clearly, provides some
absolutely essential context
that often gets lost in the
emotional debates.
First, regarding use of force,
it's a statistic that often
surprises people and directly
challenges common perceptions.
Only about 1% to 2%.
Just one to 2% of all police
public encounters involve any
physical force at all. 1 to 2%.
That seems incredibly low
compared to the narrative.
It is.
Think about the millions of
interactions happening annually
across the country.
Traffic stops, domestic calls,
noise complaints, public
assistance requests.
A vanishingly tiny fraction of
these escalate to any physical
force whatsoever.
Yet these incredibly rare
moments, almost always the most
dramatic and often captured on
video, are the ones that
overwhelmingly shape the entire
public narrative and perception
of policing.
It creates A skewed view of
daily reality.
That's a huge disparity between
the statistical reality and
public perception, almost a
statistical illusion created by
media focus.
What about police shootings?
Those are so often at the very
center of this conversation and
calls for reform.
Right.
Police shootings, specifically
civilians killed by police in
the US annually, consistently
hover around 1000 to 1100
individuals each year.
This number is tragically
consistent year after year.
What's particularly notable and
often surprising about this
figure is that it is barely
budged in decades.
Despite all the public outcry,
the waves of reforms, the
protests, technological
advancements like body cameras
and less lethal options, it
remains A persistent tragic
statistic indicating that this
particular problem is deeply
entrenched and resistant to
current solutions.
Then there are accidental
discharges, which are still
significantly under reported
across departments.
We touched on getting bitter
earlier, that grim slang for
accidental self-inflicted
gunshot wounds or even
unintended discharges that don't
cause injury but show a lapse in
control.
And large urban areas like DC
where high stress situations are
common.
It's common enough to be a
source of gallows humor among
officers.
It's a quiet, often hidden
indicator of the challenges of
managing powerful tools under
constant pressure, and a symptom
of potential training or
resource gaps.
And how do these numbers, these
training hours, these challenges
compare internationally?
Do other countries really do it
better or is it a more complex
comparison than that?
In many ways, yes, other
countries do appear to achieve
better outcomes, but with
crucial caveats that are often
overlooked.
European countries, for
instance, often require twice as
many training hours for their
police officers as the US does,
sometimes up to 1500 hours or
more.
Crucially, their training tends
to emphasize scenario based
judgement, de escalation,
conflict resolution, and social
sciences much more heavily than
a force first posture.
They also tend to have better
continuing education programs
throughout an officer's career
and consequently generally
maintain higher levels of trust
with their public.
So more training, different
focus, better trust sounds
promising.
It does.
However, it's vital to
acknowledge that these countries
also operate within vastly
different cultural contexts.
They often benefit from higher
levels of social cohesion, a
stronger sense of shared
community, common norms, less
social stratification, and,
critically, significantly less
personal firearm prevalence
among the general population in
many European nations.
It's incredible.
Precisely the paradox is this.
The public overwhelmingly wants
less force.
They want less violence from
their police.
They want more de escalation,
more compassionate responses.
Yet simultaneously, often when
the worst happens, when a truly
dangerous, violent or acute
situation unfolds like an active
shooter, a home invasion, a
kidnapping, the public demands
an instant, decisive, forceful
response.
This creates A fundamental
tension, a seemingly
irreconcilable demand, and it
means that the guard dog, that
metaphor for the police role,
stays armed and ready, his teeth
real and present, even when you
might wish he didn't bark at
all.
He has to be prepared for the
worst, for the extreme scenario,
because the public will
inevitably call for him with
urgent demands when the worst
arrives.
It's a job designed for the
worst case scenario, despite the
overwhelming majority of
encounters being routine.
That's a powerful way to put it,
and it really crystallizes the
core dilemma.
Now, let's address some
frequently asked questions that
often arise in these
discussions, synthesizing some
of the points we've covered and
giving them a bit more depth.
First up.
So if they're not social
workers, should cops just be
social workers, or should we
replace them entirely with
social workers?
The answer is nuanced but clear,
and it requires understanding
distinct roles.
Some crises absolutely do need
social workers, and there's a
growing and I think welcome
movement to send mental health
professionals or crisis
intervention teams to certain
calls that are clearly
nonviolent mental health
emergencies or low level
disputes.
That's a valid and necessary
development in public safety.
However, a law enforcement
officer is not and cannot
fundamentally be a social
worker.
Their authority flows from the
state's monopoly on force.
It's the credible threat that
someone will, if you push far
enough, if you resist lawful
orders, be forcibly stopped,
restrained or apprehended,
leading to arrest.
The authority is fundamentally
different.
Completely different.
A social worker operates on
consent, on building trust, on
therapeutic engagement, on
voluntary compliance, and Leo
ultimately operates on the
lawful ability to compel
compliance, to intervene
physically when necessary, and
to use force up to and including
lethal force when authorized and
justified.
They serve different, albeit
sometimes overlapping,
functions.
When someone is experiencing a
mental health crisis but is not
an immediate threat, a social
worker is ideal.
When someone is actively
breaking into a home or
assaulting another person or
threatening public safety with a
weapon, that's when the LE OS
distinct authority and training
become necessary.
OK.
What about the defund the police
movement?
We heard about it trending, some
cities trying partial versions.
What were the tangible outcomes?
The lessons learned from those
attempts?
Well, the US did indeed try
partial versions of defunding in
some cities, reallocating
portions of police budgets to
other social services or
alternative response models.
And in many instances it show
that certain types of calls,
particularly those involving
mental health crises,
homelessness or nonviolent
neighbor disputes, were indeed
better handled and with better
outcomes by mental health crisis
teams or non police responders.
These specialized teams could
provide more appropriate
resources and de escalation
techniques than an armed
officer.
So there was some success there.
Yes, definite successes in
diverting certain calls.
However, the reality also showed
that violent crime spikes or
acute emergencies involving
immediate threats to life still
unequivocally demand armed
responders.
When carjacking surged in some
cities, or when organized retail
theft became rampant, or when
someone called 911 because an
intruder was in their home, the
public's immediate demand was
for a rapid, armed, decisive
police response.
Even in cities that reallocated
funds, the guard dog was always
waiting at the fence line, and
society, even when it wished
otherwise, still reach for that
fundamental layer of protection
when faced with violent chaos.
The experiment revealed that
while some calls can be
diverted, the core need for a
force backed response to
violence remains.
We briefly touched on
international comparisons and
you mentioned many countries do
it better, but can you elaborate
more on the key differences?
Isn't it just a matter of
political will to replicate
their successes here?
Many do perform better on
certain metrics, yes, and
there's much to learn.
As we discussed, they often
spend significantly more time on
training, emphasizing judgement
and de escalation far more than
just tactical proficiency.
They invest in better continuing
education for their officers
throughout their careers, and
frequently enjoy higher levels
of trust for their communities,
leading to more consensual
policing.
These are all commendable and
aspirational goals for US
policing, certainly, but it's
critical to remember that these
countries also rely on vastly
different cultural contexts
which cannot be simply imported.
They typically benefit from
higher social cohesion, a
stronger sense of shared
community, shared values, norms,
which often leads to less
individualistic and more
collective problem solving.
And crucially, they have much,
much less personal firearm
prevalence among the general
population.
In many European nations, it's
exceptionally rare for civilians
to own or carry handguns, and
criminals are far less likely to
be armed with firearms during
routine encounters.
This fundamentally changes the
nature of policing encounters,
dramatically reducing the
immediate lethal threat officers
face daily, which in turn allows
for different training paradigms
and response models.
So while we can certainly learn,
it's not a direct copy paste
solution.
The societal underpinnings are
just too different and.
That slang phrase Getting bit
for an accidental,
self-inflicted gunshot wound?
Is that just a sign of sloppy
gun safety, or does it tell us
something deeper about the
challenges police face?
Sometimes, yes.
It can unfortunately indicate a
lack of proper safety,
discipline, or simply human
error under pressure.
No question.
But it's also a powerful
illustration of a larger
systemic contradiction that we
as a society often overlook.
Society, including the
individual calling 911, wants a
tool that projects deterrence.
A guard dog with teeth that are
truly capable of stopping a
threat, a weapon that is always
ready and reliable.
But often that same society
doesn't invest enough hours or
enough resources into ensuring
those officers master that tool.
They are given enough range
time, enough scenario training,
enough continuous professional
development to handle that
weapon to a level of precision
that minimizes such accidents,
especially under fatigue or
stress.
It highlights the tension
between desiring a capable
deterring force and providing
the comprehensive, ongoing
training necessary to wield that
force safely and effectively,
both for the public and for the
officers themselves.
It's a symptom of a system that
demands a powerful tool but may
not really fund its mastery,
leading to preventable incidents
that erode trust and injure
officers.
So why then, after all this
nuanced discussion, after all
the data and historical context,
do we keep returning to this
guard dog metaphor?
Why is it so essential to
understanding the police role
and cutting through the layers
of misperception?
We keep this guard dog metaphor
because it provides
uncomfortable clarity, a stark,
unsentimental truth.
It distills the essence of their
function in a way that avoids
romanticization on one hand and
unfair demonization on the
other.
You don't want that guard dog
off the leash all the time,
roaming freely, barking at
shadows, causing issues
indiscriminately.
No one wants that.
But you also absolutely do not
want him gone, vanished, nowhere
to be found, when the wolves
come to your door, when true,
violent chaos erupts.
What you want, ideally, is for
him to be trained.
You want him leashed.
You want him trustworthy.
But the fundamental reality is
that the job, when it comes down
to its core, requires teeth.
It requires the latent and
sometimes active ability to use
force to protect the vulnerable
and maintain order when all
other avenues have failed.
The metaphor reminds us of this
core, often unpalatable truth
that underpins the entire
institution of policing,
regardless of our wishes or
desires for a different reality.
That's a truly sobering
clarification pulling us back to
the stark reality of the role.
So let's bring this back to the
core message of this deep dive.
After unpacking all this, it
becomes undeniably clear a
police officer is not a Saint
Bernard with a barrel of Brandy
around its neck coming to rescue
you from a snowstorm of personal
lows.
They are not a soft place to
land when your personal code, or
someone else's collides with the
broader societal one.
They are not your confessor,
your therapist, or your tribal
elder here to mediate personal
disputes with perfect empathy
and endless time.
That's the ultimate
uncomfortable truth, the reality
stripped bare.
They are, in the end, the
state's guard dog.
They're conditioned to bark, to
deter, and, yes, to bite when
that fundamental line of
societal order is crossed.
Their training, their equipment,
their tools, their legal
mandates, they're very
designation as law enforcement
officers.
Everything about the role points
to this reality.
It is a specific difficult job
with specific difficult tools
for a specific difficult
purpose.
And this leads us to the final
provocative thought from our
source material.
It presents a profound
challenge, doesn't it, to all of
us.
If you genuinely want a world
where that guard dog is needed
less often, then you
collectively as communities, as
a society, must actively build
the conditions that make him
less necessary.
We're talking about fostering
stronger bonds between
neighbors, creating fairer
chances for the desperate,
investing in mental health and
education, and nurturing a
culture that fundamentally does
not glorify or enable the wolf
at the door, whether that wolf
is violent crime, addiction, or
profound despair.
That's the core societal
responsibility, the aspirational
goal.
But, and this is the stark
reality that we must confront,
when you have none of those
conditions, when those bonds
weaken, when opportunities
disappear, when societal
pressures breakdown or when they
simply fail under acute pressure
like a sudden act of violence,
or when a person simply chooses
to be the wolf despite all good
intentions, you will not be
calling a therapist in the
middle of the night.
You will not be calling a social
worker.
You will call the guard dog, and
when he comes, when he responds
to that desperate call, you must
not for a second act surprised
that his teeth are real and that
he's prepared to use them.
It's a powerful call to
reflection, demanding an
uncomfortable clarity from us
all.
You can choose to romanticize
the badge, to imbue it with all
these idealized qualities of
perfect wisdom and boundless
empathy, or you can choose to
demonize it, to see it only as
an instrument of oppression.
But as the source material so
eloquently states, if you want
to live with fewer guard dogs,
then you must build a society
that genuinely needs fewer.
Until then, be honest with
yourself.
A police officer is not your
therapist, your priest, or your
personal Redeemer.
He is the last argument the
state makes, the ultimate line
of defense when chaos presses at
the fence.
If you ignore that truth, if you
sugarcoat it, you'll be stunned
when the teeth come out, when
force is used.
But if you accept it, if you
fund it wisely and constrain it
justly within its proper role,
you may never have to hear the
bark.
It's a truth that demands
clarity, not comfort.
From all of us, thank you for
joining us on this deep dive
into understanding the true
nature of law enforcement, and
we encourage you to continue
seeking that uncomfortable
clarity in a world overflowing
with complex information.